françois hollande et manuel valls sont
les deux meilleurs candidats que nous
pouvons avoir
donc pour moi les choses sont très
claires il n'y a pas à les opposer
il n'y a pas posé ces questions le
président de la république a dit qu'il
donnerait sa réponse le 10 décembre
s'il est candidat je le soutiendrai pas
ce qu'il est capable de porter le bilan
de son quinquennat qui a été décrit tout
au long de ce quinquennat
à gauche comme à droite d'ailleurs parce
que les fraudeurs ne nous ont pas aidés
mais dans ce quinquennat sera
revalorisée j'en suis et j'en suis
certain s'il est candidat je le
soutiendrai
et s'il n'est pas candidat eh bien je
pense que c'est manuel valls qui est
celui qui devra prendre le flambeau
parce qu'il a été ministre pendant cinq
ans et là il a été premier ministre
depuis 2014